اذا صدمات نفسيه وجسديه كبيره خلفها
الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا من فقدان
الاحبه والاهل ورعب وقوع الزلازل والبقاء
مشردين ومخاوف من ما بعد الزلزال كانتشار
الاوبئه اضافه الى ظروف اخرى من شانها ان
تفاقم من هذه الازمه دعونا نبدا مشاهدينا
اولا من ان عدد المتضررين من جراء الزلزال
المدمر بلغ نحو 26 مليون شخص بينهم نحو
سبعه ملايين طفل في كل من سوريا وتركيا
وتعرضت الاف الابنيه اما للدمار كليا او
جزئيا وبالتالي عشرات الاف المشردين بدون
ماوى على جانبي الحدود والصدمه النفسيه
وفقا لاطباء الصحه النفسيه فهي تتوزع على
ثلاث مراحل الاولى هي الصدمه المباشره
والمفاجئه لحظه حدوث الزلزال وهي الجزء
الاسوا
المرحله الثانيه هي عند الخروج اما
المرحله الثالثه فهي عند ايجاد المتضرر
نفسه بدون نفسه بدون ماوى وبدون اهل مع
المي فراق الاحباء ومن شان هذه الكارثه ان
تخلق لدى الكثير من المتضررين
رهاب الزلزال ورهاب الزلازل وبعض انواع
اضطراب المزاج مثل الاكتئاب واضطراب ما
بعد الشده وهو ما قد يتمثل بكوابيس لدى
الاطفال والكبار اضافه الى احتمال متلازمه
دوار ما بعد الزلزال التي قد تحدث للاشخاص
الناجين الذين استشعروا الزلازل والهزات
والموجات الارتداديه فيحدث عندهم دوار
دوخه لمده اسبوع او اسبوعين بعد زلزال
الامر الذي يتطلب متابعه دائمه للعنايه
الطبيه النفسيه الى جانب الطبيه الجسديه
سيما للاطفال وهو ما يحتاج طبعا قبل ذلك
توفر الكوادر الطبيه النفسيه المتدربه
والمجهزه لهكذا حالات
[موسيقى]